Grégory Charles évidemment les gens qui
ont la chance d'aller dans des écoles
privées on peut ce problème là c'est
offert mais est-ce que ça vous inquiète
de voir dans les écoles publiques si
laisser au bon vouloir puis on peut à
l'aléatoire je pourrais que ce soit au
choix de l'école c'est pas seulement je
suis pas sûr qu'on doit être dans
l'imposition puis de toute façon il faut
se dire que comme je suis un parent moi
aussi des parents on a des grandes
attentes de l'école à la limite on
voudrait que tout soit dans l'école puis
que tout le monde s'occupe de toutes
c'est sûr que ce n'est pas possible mais
on a fait un bon choix il y a quelques
années lorsqu'on s'est dit on fait face
à de l'obésité chez les jeunes on fait
face à de l'angoisse on fait face à un
problème d'oxygénation ils ont besoin et
on s'est dit la petite physique
l'activité physique devrait être
obligatoire bon c'est pas bête mais la
musique est aussi un remède assez même
problème là c'est à dire que c'est bon
pour la santé de faire de la musique
c'est très bon c'est bon pour le niveau
la dopamine c'est bon pour le niveau de
bonheur alors on devrait tirer la même
conclusion mais c'est pas juste bon pour
ça on vient un moment où on est
extrêmement inquiet pour notre
identité et pour notre histoire et notre
culture la musique ça fait ça ça nous
permet de vivre et je veux pas faire de
peine aux gens qui font de la
littérature ou du théâtre mais de façon
bien plus populaire qui nous sommes qui
nous avons été on s'inquiète justement
sur notre rapport avec l'histoire et ben
la musique nous permet de voyager dans
le temps on s'inquiète sur l'insertion
des jeunes dans un groupe la
compréhension de l'ordre de la
collectivité la musique ça fait toutes
ces choses là donc moi je voudrais pas
imposer que je trouve que c'est
parfaitement logique
j'aimerais que les écoles viennent
toutes à la même conclusion ben oui
parce qu'on se dise attendez minutes là
il y a 2000 ans quand on enseignait un
petit nombre on considérait que
l'astronomie la géométrie l'arithmétique
et la musique c'était sur le même niveau
on trouvait que c'était important à ce
point au Venezuela un pays bien moins
fortuné que le nôtre il y a une affaire
qui s'appelle le Systema ou c'est
intégral c'est intégré dans la journée
scolaire non seulement de faire de la
musique mais de fabriquer ses propres
instruments alors c'est difficile pour
moi qui vient de la campagne ou mes
grands-parents qui avaient pas tant
d'éducation avec un piano un une
trompette une contrebasse violon
accordéon diatonique dans la maison
difficile pour moi d'imaginer qu'on
pense maintenant que la musique c'est
secondaire oui c'est sûr qu'on peut
l'apprendre à l'extérieur c'est sûr mais
il y a aussi un paquet d’autres choses à
faire à l'extérieur moi je pense que je
pense que le reportage aujourd'hui était
extrêmement important parce que ces
éducateurs là ont dit la vérité cohésion
exercice de logique cette dame qui dit
ça sculpte le cerveau parlez-moi de ça
vous vous enseignez la musique à des
jeunes vous le voyez ça développe pas
parce que les gens m'écrivaient
aujourd'hui oui mais c'est quoi
l'important c'est d'apprendre à lire et
écrire et bien sûr c'est un complément
la musique c'est une langue donc c'est
pas c'est pas faux c'est tout ce que
apprendre des langues en parallèle c'est
pas une mauvaise chose si on apprend
deux trois langues en même temps ça
accélère l'apprentissage de chacune de
ces langues mais c'est aussi des
bâtiments la musique c'est toute une
question de rythmique alors ça devient
complément pour pour les mathématiques
c'est aussi comme je le disais de
l'histoire ça devient complément pour
l'histoire c'est de l'expression c'est
aussi toute une question d'émotion il y
a plein de choses qui ne sont pas
émotionnelles dans l'enseignement qu'on
fait à l'école mais la musique se lit or
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'on constate chez
nos jeunes ces troupes d'anxiété on
s'était on s'est intéressé et on s'est
inquiété beaucoup dans les dernières
décennies de des codes suicide on le
sait que l'insertion dans le groupe
c'est favorisé par la musique la
rétention des jeunes à l'école c'est
favorisé par le sport c'est favorisé par
la musique je dis pas que ce sont les
seuls activités mais elle barre ses
activités là alors pourquoi les laisser
s'effondrer alors que un petit effort
nous permettrait au bien au contraire
d'améliorer la situation vous dites
Grégory Charles trouvons du temps pour
ça c'est important trouver des bienfaits
énormes trouve le lieu et trouvons le
temps aussi pour le faire et en plus
c'est pas comme si on venait d'inventer
une chose que là il faut se mettre à
créer une armada d'éducateur ils sont là
et ils sont volontaires et ils sont au
combien pourtant et j'ai envie pour les
gens qui sont pas convaincus de ce qu'on
dit j'aimerais qu'ils demandent alors je
quel jeune volver la main quand il a
maintenant 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans et qui
va se dire que le pire prof qui a eu à
l'école c'est son prof de musique il y a
des chances que son prof sa prof de
musique arrive dans le haut de la
hiérarchie des profits plus mémorables
et vous le savez mieux que nous tous
personne va dire
est en vieux je regrette d'avoir appris
la musique c'est une richesse incroyable
s'il y a quelque chose les gens disent à
leurs parents pourquoi tu m'as laissé
arrêter de de faire de la musique
exactement Grégory Charles c'est
toujours un plaisir merci beaucoup de ce
plaidoyer